right now i feel like we're kind of in
the middle of like a a renaissance of
like mexican rappers right i feel like
when i first got on the radio and when i
was growing up it was like mc magic
little rob like
obviously baby bash was doing this thing
but i feel like right now there's so
many
dope mexican mcs artists that are just
killing it on all levels right um you
know snow the product was just nominated
for latin grammy right um
you know we can go up and down i mean la
is kind of the epicenter of like where a
lot of these young kids are really
killing it in the latin hip-hop scene
just in hip-hop and they happen to be
mexican right um
how do you feel about like the current
state of like
uh mexican rappers
um man i love it you know i respect the
fact that everybody's out there trying
to get where they where they feel they
need to be or people that are just
pushing and
going for what you know what we've never
really been able to accomplish
um
which is opening that door for you know
the mexicans and for the hispanics and
you know people that have been
trying to do this for us for years you
know we've had episodes you know kid
frost like of course yeah you know what
i'm saying
that people that did get their
their time to shine you know what i'm
saying but i feel like the door wasn't
completely kicked in forever it was
always like one or two guys at a time
but i feel like now i mean i can think
of like 25 dudes off the top of my head
that's the difference now and then i
feel like social media and everything
else has brought that
for a little made it a little easier for
us to be able to you know show
showcase what we got and and
learn from each other which not
everybody's gonna sit here and tell you
that they that they learn from each
other but
if i see a dope artist that i can learn
from i'm definitely gonna soak up game
i'm definitely gonna appreciate whatever
he's putting out there you know
everybody out here got their chests out
and think oh i'm the biggest i'm the
baddest and that's why i don't fall into
that
category with my mind state i stick to
what what myself
my boy peter built which is jr from my
label like everybody that's from my
label jokes you know um just just
everybody that's on
the team and on the squad i try to push
them to push me if that makes sense like
you know i'm trying to
like at the same time
they're working on stuff i tell them
don't get caught up with waiting on me
you know what i mean keep doing what
you're doing keep doing what you're
doing you guys might pop before me who
knows
[ __ ] then you're gonna have to bring me
like i'm gonna bring you if i pop like
it's just a it's a square you know what
i'm saying and at the end of the day
it's like
we got to cover every corner in that
square and
that's how i feel like it needs to be
done
you know help each other help yeah let's
help you know what i mean